[Music]
alright team here we go I have looked
like some Rome rats be careful right
[Music]
first floors all boarded up
you know we face these guys before all
right my drone spawn in the second floor
got one that just passed me looks like
we got three more in the hallway they're
reinforcing the kids room fourth wall
right there they're blocking the master
bedroom looks like she's blocking the
main entrance oh I see the hostage she's
in the kids room
barricading all windows
[ __ ] they saw me drones out ok I say we
breach the garage no I'd rather not
I mean they always defend it with a
shitload of booby traps mmm I say we
drop in the roof and breach the three
second-floor windows we all come in at
once what do you guys think okay yeah
that sounds good principle free
helicopter drop Roger that
now pyro and I'll take the large window
you guys take the rest you got it yep
gotcha you guys you did wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait what you all right
yeah yeah all good all right set up it
on three one two three good job guys
yeah all right I'll get her okay
enemy is camping outside [ __ ] okay you
stay here we'll turn it floor okay go go
go hallway let's go
I see him okay
sorry guys for losing the hostage hurry
and don't worry about it
wait but listen watch out for havoc he's
still out there there there he's right
there yeah he's outside Rath watch out
I'm looking look at the time or no time
to waste let's go yeah you're right it's
getting louder yeah Oh close
[Applause]
hang on wait wait what's in the drone
alright alright hostages on the ground
through the door either during the wall
or reinforced the door upstairs is
barricaded one just grabbed her [ __ ]
this Muser is a shield the other one's
got a shield - they're facing the door
right get ready to breach what are you
thinking I'm deaf them above us
brassey's - on the north side yeah
alright I'm making indoor in the living
room
alright I gotta lay these think cover me
what where is he nevermind hurry box
taking Dante ready when you are
okay okay I'm gonna breach the ceiling
just wait for my go got it come on down
to breaching breach
cool I got her yes nice well guys let's
get out all right move it upstairs don't
get surprised all right let's go here we
go find an exit I'm okay
everything's blocked clear one out I'm
taking out the main entrance
alright I got the window with the girl
[Music]